a o'seas chief of staff says the quiet
part out loud Nancy Pelosi warns illegal
immigrants how to avoid ice and we
checked the mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show a lot to get to
done today's show the big breaking news
of course is that the Secretary of Labor
Alex Acosta is out thanks to the Jeffrey
Epstein scandal his now resigned his
resignation will be effective within the
week basically has seven days to get out
now Trump is saying that this was Alex
Acosta's decision the truth is that it
may not have been Acosta was creating so
much pressure for Trump that it made a
lot of sense for him to go there just
too many unanswered questions about how
exactly the sweetheart deal with alleged
pedophile Jeffrey Epstein went down he's
a registered sex offender in several
states Jeffrey Epstein he got this
pretty sweet deal from the prosecutors
in the state of Florida Alex Acosta was
one of those prosecutors now the case
against Acosta that he had cut some sort
of sweetheart deal it wasn't quite as
cut and dry as I think a lot of people
would like to make it there are a few
contentions that Acosta made in his own
defense that are relevant and may in
fact be true one is that we just haven't
seen all the underlying evidence in the
case we don't know how strong that
evidence was there were a lot of
witnesses who said that that Acosta did
things to them but that doesn't
necessarily amount to a sex trafficking
charge it may amount to a sexual
molestation charge on the state level
but that's a state level charge the the
trafficking charge is the federal charge
and the prostitution across state
Lauren's charge that is the federal
charge and that's what Acosta was tasked
with the real question that I have is
why the state of Florida didn't go after
Epstein if it was so cut and dry that
there were all these women coming
forward and they had the evidence that
all these women were telling the truth
why was he not in jail for statutory
rape at the very least for an extended
period of time or child molestation for
an extended period of time
those are state crimes in any case
Acosta made the defense that other
prosecutors signed off on this the judge
signed off on this that deals like this
happened on a fairly regular basis that
may be true I've talked to several
prosecutors some say true some say not
true there are a couple things that he
said in his own defense that do not ring
true he said for example that he only
stepped in with the federal government
and the power of the DA when it became
clear that the state was not going to
prosecute Epstein that's an eye
contention because the feds and the
state work on different levels you don't
have to wait for the state to not
prosecute in order to prosecute at the
federal level that would actually be
looking like double jeopardy if that
were the case but nonetheless that
particular argument by Acosta didn't
hold water also there are a lot of
unanswered questions about all of this
such as was it pressure from the defense
attorneys on the prosecutors that led to
this deal what evidence did they
actually have were they trying to shut
down the FBI investigation and all the
rest so Acosta basically had to go in
just a second well tell you what
President Trump had to say and what Alex
Acosta had to say suffice it to say once
Acosta is gone this is no longer a trump
administration scandal and then the
question is going to become okay who
else was involved and what exactly was
Jeffrey Epstein doing the going theory
right now the kind of hot fury on Wall
Street right now is the Jeffrey Epstein
who was purportedly a billionaire and
probably was not a billionaire that he
was actually making his money this is
the theory from blackmailing people and
he was trafficking in underage girls
with very famous people and then he was
blackmailing them with tape of that
information which is an astonishing
story if true we'll get to that in just
a second first they tell you I am
somebody who likes to work out a lot I
know you wouldn't you wouldn't know it
from looking at me but beneath this mild
exterior this meek exterior lies the
body of a Greek god but when I'm on the
road or when I don't get to the gym
during the day there is some way that I
need to work out and the way that I work
out is with open fit why will open fit
is awesome open fit takes all of the
complexity out of losing weight and
getting fit it's a brand-new super
simple streaming service it allows you
to work out from the comfort of your
living room and as or hotel room in my
case and as little as 10 minutes a day
open fit classes are led by some of the
most effective and engaging trainers in
the world their classes are terrific I
do them with my wife as well forget all
the complexity and the stressor on
getting fit just press play and workout
on your schedule view on your computer
web enabled TV tablet smartphone and
Roku open fit has changed the way I work
out with my code Ben you can join me on
a fitness journey that's personalized
just for you again use my code Ben and
start using open fit for your journey to
a healthier life right now during the
open fit 30-day challenge my listeners
get a special extended 30-day free trial
membership to open fit so see if you
like it you will you can lose up to 15
pounds in 30 days all you have to do is
text Ben 230
thirty thirty you will get full access
to open fit all the workouts all the
nutrition information totally free again
just text been to 30 30 30 that's been
to 30 30 30 text us to receive up to
five marketing text sent via automated
technology to your number consent not
required to purchase message and data
rates may apply membership automatically
renews you can cancel anytime go check
out open fit it really is terrific okay
so here is what President Trump had to
say according to CNBC Labor Secretary
Alex Acosta said on Friday that he will
resign amid controversy over the way he
handled the sex crimes case against
wealthy businessmen Jeffrey Epstein a
decade ago when he was US Attorney for
southern Florida a costume made the
announcement to reporters while standing
next to president Trump outside the
White House Trump said Acosta had called
him Friday morning and that it was a
Costas decision to quit which may or may
not be true you know it's quite possible
that a cost have looked at the media
coverage he figured the Trump was gonna
cut his legs out from under him anyway
better to quit than to get fired
Trump said this was him not me because
I'm with him and said I said you don't
have to do this Acosta told reporters he
did not want his involvement in
Epstein's controversy to overshadow the
administration's accomplishments Acosta
said he will officially resign a week
after his announcement deputy labor
secretary Patrick Patrick pizzelle will
take his place in an acting capacity
said President Trump Trump tweeted out
Alex was a great Secretary of Labor his
service is truly appreciated in his
resignation letter to Trump Acosta said
it has meant so much to me that you have
offered your steadfast support in our
private discussions and in your public
remarks but your agenda putting the
American people first must avoid any
distractions that resignation came only
a couple of days after Acosta gave that
press conference in which he had
defended his controversial
non-prosecution agreement that he cut
with Epstein's lawyers in 2007 when he
was the top prosecutor in Miami the
issue resurfaced on July 6th when the
politically connected Epstein's whose
friends have included Trump and former
President Bill Clinton was arrested on
sex trafficking charges by federal
prosecutors in New York last week by the
way speaking of Bill Clinton has gone
completely silent on follow-up questions
about the statement that he put out
earlier this week Clinton had put out a
statement earlier this week saying I was
only on four trips on Epstein's airplane
Secret Service was there the whole time
and then folks at the Washington
Examiner uncovered the fact that he was
on at least seven trips with Epstein and
that Secret Service in fact probably was
not present the whole time they asked
the Clinton camp about
this in Clinton went completely silent
which is suspicious and upsetting in
every possible way so Alex Acosta is out
that's not going to stop this thing from
moving forward
it'll be here's the fascinating part
what will be fascinating is to see
whether now that Acosta is out the media
coverage just drops off a cliff but you
remember in 2007-2008 Epstein was a very
prominent political player I mean been
giving money to all sorts of big-name
groups all sorts of big-name politicians
he was hobnobbing with the Clintons he
was hobnobbing with major Hollywood
figures and no one cared when he got
prosecuted
now he's getting prosecuted again and
because President Trump is in office and
because he was friendly with Trump and
because he had cut a deal with Trump's
Secretary of Labor this became a
national story again
well now that new information is coming
out that may implicate some of the
Democrats favorites it'll be interesting
to see whether the media just get off
the horse completely whether they say
okay we're not going to cover this thing
anymore now it's over it doesn't impact
Trump so therefore it's not relevant
that will be fascinating to see now
again there's all sorts of mystery that
surrounds all of this there's gonna be a
lot of other ugly material that comes
out according to the San Francisco
Chronicle and Bloomberg the mystery
surrounding Jeffrey Epstein's a private
island continues quote from the harbor
on st. Thomas the boat skims eastward
across the crystalline Caribbean takes a
turn and there it is the poem French
paradise that was the private read out
of Jeffrey Epstein an American flag on a
towering pole flutters in the breeze a
blue and white building that resembles a
temple sits atop one of the hills the
pool and cabanas are visible in the
difference no traffic on the winding
dirt roads it's quiet now on the island
of little st. James say up steam dubbed
it little st. Jess others have locals
have other names for it paedophile
Island and orgy Island this is where
Epstein convicted of sex crimes a decade
ago in Florida now charged in New York
with trafficking girls as young as 14
repaired his escape from the toil of
cultivating the rich and powerful San
Francisco Chronicle and Bloomberg report
few here doubt that Epstein is wealthy
who routinely touched down on st. Thomas
aboard his private jet before being
whisked by helicopter to a 72 acre
retreat he spent many millions after
buying it for about eight million bucks
in 1998 carving roads planting scores of
40-foot palms building several vias and
temple structure which was taught by a
gold
dome until hurricane Irma blew it off
according to locals yet the size and
source of Epstein's fortune are as much
a source of speculation here as they are
on Wall Street bankers and money
managers wonder exactly what his
business entailed with theories ranging
from helping the ultra-rich reduce their
taxes to buying and selling currencies
read Weingarten a lawyer perhaps teens
didn't immediately return a voicemail
message seeking comment for the story
there's no question that he has the
assets that are worth an awful lot of
money
he has companies that holds his
Gulfstream Jets he obviously owns a
townhouse in New York that's worth more
than a hundred million dollars but it is
unclear where exactly he was getting
that money in the first place
the only unusual aspect of the main
residence a former worker said he was
aware of because they've interviewed
people who worked on Epstein's estate
here were these security boxes in two
offices the level of secrecy around a
steel safe in Epstein's office in
particular suggested it contain much
more than just money outside of an
occasional visit by a housekeeper no one
was allowed in these rooms so obviously
everybody wondering what's in that safe
we'll have to deploy Geraldo Rivera to
go find out what exactly is in the safe
so all of this is is deeply suspicious
of course new victims are coming forward
on a near-daily basis with regard to
Epstein the fact that this guy escaped
prosecution for so long is truly
astonishing
according to Miami Herald at least a
dozen new victims have come forward to
claim they were sexually abused by
Jeffrey Epstein even as the
multi-millionaire money manager tries to
convince a federal judge to allow him to
wait a sex-trafficking trial from the
comfort of the same 77 million-dollar
Manhattan mansion where he's accused of
luring teenage girls into unwanted sex
acts apparently since Saturday four
separate women have reached out to New
York lawyer David Boies and at least 710
other women have approached other
lawyers who have represented dozens of
apps teens alleged victims in the past
Jack's Corolla a Palm Beach attorney
said that at least five women all of
whom are minors at the time of their
alleged encounters with Epstein have
reached out either to him or Fort
Lauderdale Fort Lauderdale lawyer Brad
Edwards Scarola said the people we are
speaking to our underage in Florida and
in New York they are not individuals
whose claims have previously been part
of any law enforcement investigation all
of this could get quite ugly but will
the media's interest wane
now that the Trump administration is
really no
longer involved we will find out come
Monday if I've seen us out of the
headlines you will know that a lot of
the coverage here was driven by
something a little bit different than
what people said it was driven by a
namely outrage over the treatment of
underage women it should be driven by
that I don't think the media's coverage
was really really driven by it we'll
find out though maybe I'm wrong okay in
just a second we're gonna get to the big
political story of the day which is the
Democrats really veering harder the left
I know this has been the story of the
last few years but they're doing it on a
daily basis and it's getting more and
more extreme I'll get to that in just a
second first right now at my house we're
doing a lot of home renovation and that
includes redoing our entire kitchen well
that means that we can't cook in that
kitchen and that means that we have to
bring a lot of food in from the outside
this has made for us door - absolutely
indispensable and it could be
indispensable to you as well door -
connects you to your favorite
restaurants in your city
ordering is super easy just use the door
- app and choose what you want to eat -
sure we'll bring it to you anywhere you
are not only is that burger place you
love on tour - already
there are over 300 10,000 other amazing
restaurants door - connects you with
door to door delivery in over 3300
cities all 50 states and canada order
from your local go to or choose from
your favorite chains like Chipotle
Wendy's chick-fil-a the Cheesecake
Factory don't worry about dinner let
dinner come to you with door - I mean
listen I eat out too much and door -
makes it possible for me to eat in Wow
eating out which is pretty great right
now our listeners can get five bucks off
their first order of fifteen bucks or
more when you download the door - app
and enter promo code Ben that's five
bucks off your first order when you
download the door - app from the App
Store and enter promo code Ben again
that is promo code Ben for five bucks
off your first order from door - go
check them out right now they're awesome
and use our promo code Bennet listen
though we sent you and get five bucks
off your first order okay so the
Democrats are now saying the quiet part
out loud increasingly and it's it's
amazing all they had to do was not be
crazy it's all they had to do and they
were completely incapable of doing it
and so they continue to be utterly and
and completely insane so here is a story
from the Washington Post about psychotic
labardi who is the supposed genius
behind a OSI according to the Washington
Post magazine I mean the kind of glow
coverage that radical leftists received
from the mainstream media is truly
incredible it's a long piece titled
a o C's chief of change psychic our body
isn't just running her office he's
guiding a movement whoo I remember when
they used to say this sort of stuff
about staffers from Paul Ryan there'd be
a staff of Paul Ryan putting out a big
plan on how to reform entitlements and
the Washington Post would run huge
stories about how this nearly anonymous
staffer was actually supremely powerful
a genius wonderful lovely the media's
love affair with the radical left is the
great under-covered story in American
politics except by folks on talk radio
people in the podcast world than the
alternative media here is the story on a
Wednesday morning in late May emissaries
of two of the strongest political voices
on climate change convened at a coffee
shop a few blocks from the US Capitol
psychotic labardi chief of staff to
representative Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
was there to meet Sam Ricketts climate
director for Washington governor jay
Inslee who is running for president
almost exclusively on a platform of
combating climate global warming a newly
released plank of Inslee's climate
change agenda had caught the attention
of Chakrabarti and his boss who had
tweeted that Inslee's quote climate plan
is the most serious and comprehensive
one to address our crisis in the 2020
field pleased by the positive reception
from the demands in green New Deal wing
of the climate struggle Ricketts had set
up this meeting with Chakrabarti to
establish a personal connection and
share approaches to climate advocacy now
there's a punchline to this story here's
the punchline just wait for it you ready
here's the punch line for the story so
Chakrabarti is meeting with the climate
director for washington governor jay
Inslee one of the million anonymous
people running for president on the
Democratic side of the aisle Inslee's
big spiel is that he only cares about
climate change Chakrabarti told this
staffer Sam Ricketts quote Congrats on
the rollout that was pretty great
Ricketts said thank you again for the
kudos you guys offered we wanted to be a
pacesetter in the field I think we're
there now I wanted to ask you for input
in addition to hearing what you guys are
working on Chakrabarti had an unexpected
disclosure
he said the interesting thing about the
green new deal is it wasn't originally a
climate thing at all
Ricketts greeted this startling notion
with an attentive
carface reports The Washington Post do
you guys think of it as a climate thing
Chakrabarti continued because we really
think of it as a how do you change the
entire economy thing so that's saying
the quiet part out loud right there one
of these suspicions of people on the
right for a long time has been the
global warming movement the this entire
we have to restructure the entire global
economy in order to bring down the
climate and then people on the right
point out well even if you did all the
things you are talking about that would
not actually lower climate change in any
market degree you could completely
devastate the economy of the United
States China and India would still be
providing a huge bulk of the carbon
emissions that are allegedly leading to
global warming and are leaving global
warming by International Panel on
Climate Change Intergovernmental Panel
on Climate Change estimates the
suspicion has been that it really isn't
about lowering climate that it really
has been about a marxist redistribution
scheme whereby you take down the
American economy and then you
redistribute those resources to
quote-unquote poorer countries or you
undercut capitalism in favor of a global
redistributionist system and that's
really what this is about
and Chakrabarti is saying this out loud
my chakrabarti is saying what we are
doing is we are using global warming as
basically the opening for us to
restructure the entire American economy
now Ricketts who's the staffer for
Inslee I love this he responds yeah then
he said no then he said I think it's
it's it's a dual it's both rising to the
challenge that is existential around
climate and it is building an economy
that contains more prosperity more
sustainability in that prosperity more
broadly shared prosperity
equitability and justice throughout
chakrabarti like the answer he said the
thing I think you guys are doing that's
so incredible is you guys are actually
figuring out how to do it and make it
work
the comprehensive plan word fits
together I'd love to get into a
situation where everyone's trying to
just outdo each other and then
Chakrabarti said I'll be honest my view
is I think you guys aren't going big
enough and then Ricketts answered well
you know we're not done when it comes to
a nationwide economic mobilization
there's more to come on this front and
other key components were going to be
rolling forward speak to some of the key
justice elements of this insuring every
communities got a part of this so notice
how the conversation goes now this is
all taking place in front of a
Washington Post reporter so they are
being a lot more open than you would
think they would be talking in front of
a Washington Post reporter
except that the Washington Post reporter
is busy drooling into a cup apparently
as all of this happens so Chakrabarti
says we're gonna restructure the entire
American economy and climate change is
basically just a lever a
public-relations lever for us to do
exactly that and then enslie's guys like
well no but yeah and then Chakrabarty is
saying well you know let's go even
further and then Ricketts gets excited
yeah let's do that man
let's restructure the American economy
nationwide economic mobilization justice
community the Washington Post says
Ricketts kept laying down cords in
Chakrabarty zki it was an acknowledgment
of just how far inside establishment
Washington the progressive movement has
reached everything is intersectional now
including decarbonisation the
Chakrabarti said told The Washington
Post reporter I like to show my cards
and see people's reactions I just wanted
to get a sense of where they're coming
from they seem open and hungry and want
to do stuff in my minds an ideal
situation is we have a president
surrounded by a bunch of people who are
constantly thinking how could we go
bigger bolder faster better on
everything I don't know if Inslee's
gonna be President but if it runs a
really good campaign maybe he ends up
running a big agency
what's the mindset he's gonna bring to
that agency amazing Wow and then and
then of course we get 4,000 words of
absolute drool with regard to
Chakrabarti from the Washington Post now
the hilarious thing is that Nancy Pelosi
and the other members of the Democratic
Party want Chakrabarti out they want him
out because he is promoting a o'seas
notion that Nancy Pelosi and the
moderate Democrats are a bunch of
racists he's once weeding out their a
bunch of Jim Crow racists so a bunch of
black Democrats today we're ripping on
the Justice Democrats were largely led
by Chakrabarti and saying why are you
guys all only attacking black Democrats
from the south you know you called Nancy
Pelosi a racist for opposing you you
seem kind of racist for opposing us
so it's an intersectional crap fight
over in the Democratic Party totally
what they deserve but this is what
happens when you spin down that wild
left rabbit hole we'll get some more of
the wild left's rabbit hole in just one
second first then I am NOT a great
sleeper this is particularly true and
I'm on the road the reason I sleep worse
on the road is because not only don't I
have the mattress that I love I also do
not have the sheets that I need the
sheets that I need boil and branch boil
and branch eats are better than any
sheets you've ever slept on you probably
haven't thought very much about the
sheets you're sleeping on you got it as
like a wedding gift and even sleeping
for a while where he went out to the
local store and you just bought whatever
has had the highest thread count
that's not how nice sheets work if you
want nice sheets you need to go to bowl
and branch everything bowline branch
makes from bedding to blankets is made
from pure 100% organic cotton
it means they start out supersoft they
get even softer over time you buy
directly from them so you're essentially
paying wholesale prices luxury sheets
can cost up to a thousand bucks in the
store bull and brand cheats are only a
couple of hundred bucks everyone who
tries Boleyn brand sheets loves them
shipping is free you can try them for 30
nights there's no risk no reason not to
give them a try to get you started right
now my listeners get 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets at bull and branch
com promo code Ben go to bull and branch
calm today for 50 bucks off your first
set of sheets
that's bol el and branch calm promo code
Ben Bowlin branch calm promo code Ben I
promise you're gonna love at these
sheets they are just amazing they're so
good we threw out the rest of our sheets
really and we only have bullet branch
sheets no bull and branch calm promo
code Ben go check them out so the left
has moved so far to the left now the
Chakrabarti
being positive is a hero openly saying
that the green new deal is not about
being green it is much more about the
new deal that all this really is is
about restructuring the entirety of the
American economy you think that's a
strong pitch to the vast majority of
Americans who are looking at rising
wages for looking at a Dow Jones
Industrial Average above twenty seven
thousand who are looking at an
unemployment rate of 3.7 percent and
sayings themselves what we really need
is a radical restructuring of this
economy you think this is a strong pitch
but this is where Democrats are going
this is where they're going they're
going with we want to restructure the
entire American economy and also we're
gonna call each other and you racist no
I have to say I'm really enjoying the
spectacle of aoc going after Pelosi and
calling Pelosi racist because Pelosi as
we pointed out on yesterday's show has
been downplaying a o'seas impact inside
the caucus and telling AOC to stop
attacking fellow Democrats right that's
been that's been delicious so a oh she's
been attacking Pelosi she said yesterday
that not only is Nancy Pelosi a racist
basically and she said that she's
attacking women of color and they said
I'm not saying you're a racist I'm just
saying you're attacking women of color
which means you're a racist and then she
followed that one up by saying her
attacking us at a time when we were
receiving death threats so she's a oh
she is using the exact same tactics on
Nancy Pelosi that she has used on people
like me on people on Fox News
on anyone who has ever said anything
negative about AOC she's using the exact
same tactics on Nancy Pelosi what's
hilarious is that Democrats are now
coming out and saying this is really
disingenuous for doing this to Nancy
Pelosi right it was disingenuous the
whole time you rubes
it was disingenuous elide the entire
time you were happy when it was knocking
on people you don't like
but as soon as she's knocking on Nancy
Pelosi then it's god this lady's out of
control what's she doing why is she
playing the race card on Nancy Pelosi
that seems dishonest yes that's right it
is dishonest it was dishonest the entire
time it was dishonest the entire time
but you're only allowed to say it I
guess when it targets Nancy Pelosi
now speaking of AOC and Nancy Pelosi the
truth is that the only thing that Nancy
Pelosi really dislikes about AOC is
exactly what you see in that article
from her chief of staff which is that AO
she keeps saying all the quiet parts out
loud when it comes to policy Nancy
Pelosi doesn't radically disagree with
AOC on any of this stuff she just thinks
that AOC is pie in the sky and doesn't
have any way of achieving what AOC is
going for but on policy there are not a
lot of disagreement let's take an
example so AOC now says that she wants
to axe the entire Department of Homeland
Security now I am fine with the idea of
devolving a lot of the services of
Homeland Security back to the Secretary
of Defense
I thought the creation of the Department
of Homeland Security in the first place
was just the creation of another giant
federal bureaucracy that would grow and
grow because every department does
but when AOC says she wants to ax the
Department of Homeland Security she
doesn't mean she then wants to read Ella
gate all of the parts back to their
original apartments according to the the
San Francisco Chronicle although some
activists have urged the government to
abolish its immigration enforcement arm
representative Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
came out in favor of eradicating the
entire Department of Homeland Security
not replacing it just eradicating it the
department's creation after the
terrorist attack of September 11th
significantly threatened American civil
liberties
Acacio Cortes said she said she wanted
to get rid of homeland security should
people sounded the alarm back then that
these agencies are extrajudicial that
they lack effective oversight it is
baked into the core foundational
structure of these agencies so she's not
talking about how she would replace
their services she just wants it gone
okay so who exactly is then going to
protect the homeland when I say I don't
want extra bureaucracy it's because I
think we don't need an extra Department
to do the same work when she says she
wants to get rid of the depart
of Homeland Security she means she wants
to disband ice she wants to get rid of
all of the enforcement agencies former
White House deputy chief of staff Karl
Rove said that this was quote moronic
stupid naive and um went direct to the
thesaurus and came up with that which is
exactly true some members of Congress
worried that the White House originally
was concealing the department's true
cost that's true some conservative
Republicans were opposed to it I was not
in favor of setting up a DHS at the time
if I recall correctly still that is not
what Ocasio Cortez is talking about
she's talking about getting rid of the
services of the DHS not read ella gating
them Nancy Pelosi meanwhile is just as
radical or more radical than AOC not on
the DHS but on ice how do we know this
because yesterday Nancy Pelosi
released a statement in which she
suggested that illegal immigrants
basically hide from ice it's amazing she
warned her caucus on Thursday about
president Trump's plans immigration
raids this weekend she urged members to
spread information about undocumented
immigrants legal rights speaking to
closed-door whips Pelosi urged members
to spread the parties know your rights
campaign according to two people in the
room Democrats took the same approach
earlier this year
Pelosi told members she plans to reach
out to religious leaders to encourage
them to oppose the efforts as she did
last month Pelosi even issued a
statement trying to explain to people
that they did not have to allow icy
agents into their homes and she said
that if you show if somebody shows up at
your house and they ask if there's an
illegal immigrant there you just say you
don't have a warrant to come into my
house and the illegal immigrant hides
upstairs there's nothing they can do
about it there are warrants out against
these illegal immigrants the vast
majority of people's rump is talking
about raiding and resting our people
with outstanding warrants not merely in
many of these cases not merely people
who have overstayed their visas but
people who have committed separate
crimes and for whom there are
outstanding warrants it's an amazing
thing to watch Democrats who are now
openly stumping for people to escape the
the hand of the law
Pelosi came out in a press conference
yesterday and she said the president
Trump is quote-unquote terrorizing
families it's about values that the
president does not seem to share and we
saw this morning when he announced his
heartless raids on
families this coming Sunday and as they
prepare to go to church they feel very
threatened and scared by these raids so
hopefully the president will think again
about it
families belong together every person in
America has rights these families are
hardworking members of our communities
in our country this brutal action will
terrorize children and tear families
apart
hey Pelosi is talking about a blanket
amnesty right here she's talking about a
blanket amnesty everybody who is in the
country illegally now effectively
becomes an American citizen who gets to
live her forever
that is what she was talking about even
people against whom there's an
outstanding warrant because that's who
we're talking about here and as I say
most of the people who are going to be
targeted are people who have committed
other crimes other than just being in
the country illegally so here's what
Pelosi did she apparently read from a
card at her weekly press conference she
said quote a nice deportation warrant is
not the same as a search warrant if that
is the only document ice brings to a
home raid agents do not have the legal
right to enter a home if ice agents
don't have a warrant signed by a judge a
person may refuse to open the door and
let them in so she's trying to tell
people exactly how to avoid ices legal
enforcement actions
it's unbelievable Kamala Harris is doing
the same thing of course she appeared on
MSNBC with Rachel Maddow and she made
the argument that what President Trump
was doing with immigration rates which
by the way have taken place under every
single president including under
President Obama she called them a crime
against humanity it's a crime against
humanity now to arrest people upon whom
there's an outstanding warrant which
does raise the question as to what the
hell she was doing his Attorney General
of California when presumably she was
authorizing people to be arrested she
said the guy has now got to start
distracting people from the fact that he
made all these promises that I believe
he had no intention of fulfilling he has
failed to perform on every level by
which we should measure a president and
so he's going to create as he often does
this distraction and do these raids
which is a crime against humanity I
believe in the way he is coming about
this and the way he's been handling the
issue when you have babies in cages
that's not what this raid is not about
babies in cages is about people who have
outstanding warrants against them I mean
the this is radical radical stuff in
Chicago Mayor Lori Lightfoot is doing
the same thing she says will never
tolerate ice tearing our families apart
laid foot said the threat of raids has
forced illegal
immigrants to hide in fear she said the
Chicago PD will not cooperate with ice
entertaining residents normalize have
access to any Chicago police databases
so just to get this straight
according to the Supreme Court and the
Obama administration if a state decides
that they are going to help arrest
illegal immigrants as they did in
Arizona that is illegal under the
Supremacy Clause if however a locality
decides to defy ice and apparently
create objective barriers to them
arresting people that's just good policy
Harris said I assume that what mayor
Lightfoot is doing in Chicago similar to
what Mayor breed will do in San
Francisco what mayor Garcetti will do in
Los Angeles which is to say we don't
want the limited resources of local law
enforcement to go into the job that the
federal government has got to do we want
our local law enforcement to be trusted
by our community and not be feared by
our community said I don't want to fix
him of crimes be afraid to wave down
that patrol car when she has been hurt
for fear that if she stops that police
officer she's going to be deported yeah
that's a separate issue we are talking
about active ice raids now we're not
talking about whether somebody witnesses
a crime reports it and then we checked
their immigration status that's a
different issue we are talking about
active ice raids that are being
obstructed by local governments here by
the way if you speak to any cop anywhere
in the country and this particularly
true in Los Angeles if you want to talk
about one of the problematic enforcement
issues they have is that they cannot
arrest illegal immigrants and coordinate
with the federal government to do so a
disproportionate number of people who
are in California's prisons right now
are illegal immigrants our people who
came here illegally and were not
deported and committed crimes in the
United States there are a lot of illegal
immigrants where in American prisons
right now and we're not deported and
just a second we'll get to the the
extreme position of the Democratic Left
when it comes to ice then we'll get to
why it is the Joe Biden continues to
soar in polling these are not unrelated
questions first it is that glorious time
of the week when I give a shout out to a
daily wire subscriber today it is
firefighter Bradley top live on
Instagram was experiencing a harsh
reality in the pursuit of living a
healthy life filled with vitamin LT in
the in the pic Bradley who is sitting on
his couch taking a big swig out of the
world's most elite beverage vessel
rights mother of Zeus these leftist
tears are salty
hashtag leftist Tears tumblr yes as 2020
approaches they will probably get even
saltier so stay hydrated my friend and
keep up the good work out there in
Oregon really appreciate what
do Bradley really pretty if you want to
be featured in our every Friday leftist
cheers tumbler feature all you have to
do is become an annual subscriber
because with that comes the leftist
cheers tumbler with it comes the
greatest of all beverage vessels and
then you could be featured
it's just 99 bucks a year and when you
spend that 99 bucks a year
you also get amazing goodies like you
get our Sunday special on Saturday this
week Sunday special Daniel Hannan the UK
Member of Parliament for the EU
Parliament he joins us Daniel is a
really tremendous scholar and a great
thinker here's a little bit of what it
sounds like Britain in the end was not
prepared to become a province of a
country called Europe we want to have
the best and closest relations with our
neighbors they will remain our friends
and our allies and our suppliers and our
customers but we want to live under our
own laws just like any other country so
that is it's a great interview Daniel
Hannan is a brilliant guy a really learn
it guy we have some disagreements we
have a lot of agreement he really
explains I think in depth what brexit is
all about so definitely worthwhile and
again when you subscribe to get it a day
early and you get extra material behind
the paywall as well so go become a
subscriber we have all sorts of goodies
coming for subscribers by the way while
you're at it you should go subscribe to
something that is called it's a new
podcast that we are involved with called
Apollo 11 what we saw later in things I
like I'll play you a little bit of what
that is about but it is super cool so
you should go to Apple podcasts right
now iTunes anywhere you listen to
podcasts and go subscribe to Apollo 11
what we saw also go subscribe over daily
wire so you get everything that we do we
are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
you
so as I say the Democrats becoming
increasingly radical when it comes to
ice Pete Buddha judge who it is amazing
that the gap between the amount of media
coverage and money the Buddha judge has
received in his polling numbers so
Buddha judge is solidly second-tier he
is pulling in the RealClearPolitics
polling average about 5% you know
despite all of the media coverage which
you would think would put him at like
ten twelve percent he is still pulling
in the Real Clear Politics poll average
at five point three percent which is
nowhere near the leaderboard the
leaderboard right now has Biden at
twenty seven more in Sanders and Harris
all tied at 15 according to the polling
average the latest poll comes from the
NBC news/wall Street Journal poll that
has Biden at 26 Warren at 19 Sanders at
13 and Harris at 13 so Harris lagging a
little bit which was kind of surprising
Buddha judge hs7 Buddha judge continues
to say radical things with a straight
face here he is saying that the ice
raids make Americans less safe he'll
have to explain why arresting people who
are here criminally makes Americans less
safe I also want to get your response to
the news this morning of mass
immigration raids set to start in cities
across the country over the weekend well
this makes America less safe look I
don't think anybody disagrees that there
ought to be you know law enforcement
protecting people from from danger
that's not what this is about this is
targeting people who are caught in a
broken system where there should be a
pathway to citizenship and again in a
community like mine if rumors start
going on about rates let alone if it
starts actually happening
it immediately makes the community less
safe okay so the argument is that if you
start arresting illegal immigrants they
won't come forward to report crimes well
again these ice raids are just as
Obama's were are largely going to target
people who have outstanding warrants and
not just warrants for overstaying their
visas if we're just arresting everybody
overstaying their visas they're like 10
million people in the country 11 million
minimum maybe 20 according to some
estimates that's not what this is Jared
palace is going even further
Jared palace is the governor of Colorado
he said if true these reports are of
great concern in another failure of
leadership by the Trump administration
instead of working with Congress to find
a real comprehensive solution to our
broken immigration system the president
is unfortunately focused on creating
uncertainty and fear these actions make
our communities less se
an increased distrust of law enforcement
Colorado celebrates our immigrant
communities we will not allow the public
safety of Coloradans to be held hostage
by the Trump administration so here is
the Democratic position as of now get no
wall on the southern border to stop
illegal immigration get rid of the
criminal section of the u.s. code about
illegal immigration that makes it a
criminal offence to cross between border
patrol entry points between points of
entry on the border get rid of that so
it's not-it's just a civil offense he
basically got a ticket then you're
released into the interior of the United
States also you can't support anyone so
if people overstayed their visa we
should never have an immigration raid we
should never deport anyone so what they
are calling for is open borders and
blanket amnesty there is no other way to
read the combined policy of what they're
talking about have they said anything
about border enforcement anywhere in
here anywhere in here it's unbelievable
all they had to do was be reasonable all
they had to do was say listen we think
that President Trump is overstating the
case on the evils of illegal immigration
we think that it is not nearly as
dangerous as he says it is but we
understand that any sovereign country
has to protect our borders and that's
why we would increase funding on the
border that's why we would provide
better resources for border patrol so
they can take care of people inhumane
fashion on the border and that's why we
would create a stage-by-stage program to
make all the illegal immigrants in the
United States actual actual citizens
right they could they could push a
quote-unquote moderate program and it
could probably knock Trump for being
quote-unquote too extreme instead
they've reacted to Trump's immigration
position by going so far to the left and
this is where the Democrats are
completely miss reading the tea leaves
here it's pretty amazing
they have mistaken the fact that people
find Trump to be an off-putting
personality for the idea that everything
Trump says is not only wrong but 100
percent wrong and they have to go 180
degrees the opposite so they can't just
go ten degrees the opposite and kind of
deflect off some of the good points that
Trump is making and then make
quote-unquote better points if that's
what you think
more reasonable points instead they've
decided what we have to do is run
directly the opposite direction so as
Trump says protect the border we say
open the border we say arrested no one
Trump says will arrest everyone instead
of us saying well no we'll arrest some
people we'll arrest no one and we'll
encourage more people to cross that
border and will disband the Department
of Homeland Security and we'll make an
anon criminal offense to cross
points of entry will encourage people to
swim that Rio Grande will encourage
people to overstay their visas if
Democrats think this is a winning
proposition I don't know they're high
it's unbelievable
in that they're in Colorado smoking up
dope with with governor Paulo's it's
unreal
President Trump says I don't believe in
climate change I think climate change is
a hoax it's a Chinese hoax yada ya
instead of Democrats saying no it's not
a hoax but we are not going to sink the
United States economy we're gonna come
up with some reasonable plans for
government funding of decarbonisation
facilities which is a new thing they're
drying out in Britain right now instead
of them saying you know there are
certain ways that we can sort of curb
our use of carbon instead of them being
reasonable about any of this they're not
they're saying you know what we're gonna
do we're gonna radically restructure the
entire American economy along the lines
of World War two so Trump says climate
change doesn't exist not only does it
exist it is the greatest crisis that has
ever faced humanity and we're going to
seize control of the means of production
the way that we did in World War two
effectively and then we're gonna
restructure the entire American economy
on the back you think that's a winning
message guys you really think that most
Americans aren't going to look down go
whoa this Trump guy is weird but you
guys are out of your minds you really
think that's the direction this is gonna
go thus Joe Biden is leading the field
despite the fact that he is a lack
luster candidate a deeply lackluster
candidate now in a second we're gonna
get to Joe Biden and his lackluster nuts
hey so Joe Biden is again leading all
the polling he's only up by a few points
I don't think he ends up being the
nominee if he had been sticking around
in the mid-30s I think maybe he'd be the
nominee but he has been gradually
sliding him down and so is Bernie
Sanders and this is the important thing
as Bernie Sanders Falls a lot of that
support is going to Elizabeth Warren
Elizabeth Warren is at this point in
it's a three-person race it's Elizabeth
Warren its Kamala Harris it's Joe Biden
and right now you'd have to say
advantage probably Elizabeth Warren just
because it's gonna be easier for
Warren's rest away control of the
Sanders voters then it's going to be for
Harris to rest away total control of the
Biden voters although it's been pretty
easy for to grab a big segment of that
in any case the only reason that Biden
is still alive is a reason he is running
away from so Joe Biden is still alive in
this race because he is moderate
because he is a known quantity instead
Joe Biden has been trying to head off
the radicals of the past by becoming
radical himself and that is not going to
work because the truth is that he is not
passionate about the the wild Left
nonsense of the Democratic Party so he's
also not a very good candidate is the
sad truth for Joe Biden
so yesterday Joe Biden gave a long
meandering foreign policy speech in
which he ripped into President Trump and
talked about Trump
it was incredibly boring it didn't
really do anything for him not only did
it not do anything for Matt Turner
remind everybody that the Obama
administration's foreign policy really
sucked it was it was probably the worst
aspect of the administration they left
the Middle East in absolute flames they
left Iran in control of regional power
but here was Joe Biden ripping in Trump
Donald Trump is absolutely corroded our
country's credibility this president has
bankrupted America's word in the world
at the moment he's alienated us from the
very democratic allies we need most
troopas taken a battering ram to the
NATO alliance he treats us like it's
some kind of American run protection
racket he just doesn't get it I really
don't think he gets it okay well I'll
tell you who doesn't get it was the
Obama administration which you talk
about undermining our Democratic allies
try Israel and Britain and Poland there
are a lot of Democratic allies that the
Obama administration left out there in
the dust Biden's record is not all that
good the only thing that's keeping him
alive is that he's a known quantity
he feels solid he feels stable but
lately he's been feeling wavering he's
been feeling old that's why he's not
going to be the nominee and so you're
gonna end up with one of these radicals
now that would theoretically lead
President Trump into a pretty good
position because the more radical the
Democrats are the better off for
President Trump so for example President
Trump yesterday made an announcement
that he would not actually force a
citizenship question on to the census
instead he should an executive order
ordering his other agencies to start
asking questions of local agencies about
the number of illegal immigrants
underneath them this avoids the
constitutional problem that was created
by the latest Supreme Court decision he
decided not to go up against the Supreme
Court he announced this executive order
no constitutional crisis or anything
like that and then he launched into what
is
his solid campaign right his solid
campaign is that far left Democrats are
attempting to undermine the integrity of
the United States by concealing the
number of illegal immigrants in the
country this happens to be true here is
Trump explaining today I'm here to say
we are not backing down on our effort to
determine the citizenship status of the
United States population as shocking as
it may be far left Democrats in our
country are determined to conceal the
number of illegal aliens in our midst
they probably know the numbers far
greater much higher than anyone would
have ever believed before maybe that's
why they fight so hard ok so yeah he is
not wrong about all of this and so when
he campaigns against the Democrats I've
been saying all along if he campaigns
against their programs and he campaigns
against the radicalism it'll be fine if
however he gets caught up in the in the
fun of being a troll then trouble awaits
and this is what happened yesterday at
the social media got together so the
media totally botched the coverage of a
lot of this so there's one particular
area where the media not only botched
the coverage did you slide about it's
Jim Acosta
lied about an exchange that took place
between a quote-unquote reporter for
Playboy he's not actually a reporter's
name is Brian karamja supposed a
journalist and this reporter actually
will play the tape he actually screamed
at the people who were there and then he
was confronted by Sebastian Gorka who's
a another radio host on Salem radio
network here was the exchange as it
actually happened and then I'll show you
what Jim Acosta said about it don't be
sad this is a group of people that are
eager for demonic possession
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey just for the record he'd kick your
punk ass okay so so that was the
exchange now here's the way Jim Acosta
actually characterized that said White
House officials invited from social
media allies to sit in the Rose Garden
but after the event was over West Wing
AIDS did nothing when those social media
figures began to verbally abuse
reporters who are trying to do their
jobs
a good snapshot of how pres is treated
by White House you heard the exchange
this quote-unquote reporter Brian kerim
said that everyone in the garden was
eager for demonic possession okay that's
not journalism
that's some serious journalism right
there Brian kerim serious journalist
Brian Karen Gorka confronting him was
the least of the problems Gorkhas an
opinion host Brian kerim is supposed to
be in a journalist he's not a journalist
he's a joke and the fact that he was
confronted by gorica script now does any
of this sort of stuff help the Trump
administration and the image of
stability they need to project of course
not there's two separate questions here
one is our people like Brian Karen
terrible the answer is yes the second
question is why are you having a bunch
of people who are at the very least
deeply controversial
to the White House in the first place
like there are a bunch of people who are
at the White House in this particular
group of folks who were basically I mean
have been involved in conspiracy
theorizing seth rich conspiracy
theorizing all sorts of stuff that makes
from vulnerable to the charge that he's
bringing a bunch of people who ought not
be at the White House to the White House
and why would Trump open himself up to
that what is the benefit of that now
maybe it's to motivate the base but I
promise you guys all right like everyone
knows the base is motivated it's it's
dumb and frankly it's wrong I mean
people who conspiracies about seth rich
should probably not be at the White
House it really should not be okay
because that was gross you know if the
president wants to win reelection all he
has to do is shut
hell up and let the Democrats be who the
Democrats are and then pointed them just
stare at them and point to them it's it
it's all he has to do okay time for some
mailbag because it is a Friday so Ethan
says hey Ben love the show with both
party bases getting further from the
center do you think it could lead to a
dramatic split within either party I
think it is unlikely that there will be
a dramatic split inside the Republican
Party I think the Democratic Party I
think party capture is more likely than
a dramatic split mainly because I don't
think that the the American political
system allows for a powerful split the
same way that it did back in the 1850s
when the Republican Party split off from
the Whig party where he had multiple
parties the Free Soil party was a party
you had a bunch of different parties
that were running in the 1850s as the
parties began to crack up and fall apart
I don't think that you're gonna see the
same thing it's much easier to capture a
party as President Trump did the
Republican Party or as AOC is currently
capturing the Democratic Party than it
is to split off and do your own thing
and I don't think that the lines are
clearly enough drawn so you would need
one major issue where everyone disagrees
not merely a tactical question but an
actual political question so the reason
the Whig party split is because some of
the party wanted slavery gone and some
of the party wanted slavery maintained
with a Stephen Douglas like deal in this
particular case what is the split issue
in the Republican Party there's fairly
unanimous support for pro-life laws for
example there's not a split wedge issue
inside the Republican Party inside the
Democratic Party Pelosi and AOC disagree
about tactics but not much else
Pelosi is happy to Pat all of the
intersectional allies on the head just
so long as they back her progressive
agenda and they agree with her
progressive agenda so why wouldn't they
go along with that so the sort of ugly
rhetoric that you're seeing inside both
parties the infighting I don't think
that ends in a split bob says hey Ben
after seeing all the evidence how can
you believe the moon landing was real
take for instance that the American flag
is blowing in the wind in the famous
Apollo 11 photo since there's no air in
space how can the flag rip oh it had to
be on a soundstage
well it wasn't not only was it not on a
soundstage there is a fantastic series
that referred to it honest already
called Apollo 11 what we saw it's coming
out very soon you should go subscribe to
it and listen to every detail along the
way as we were
in the space race as we land in a man on
the moon bill Whittle the host does a
great job of debunking a lot of these
particular myths about the flag rippling
it's the momentum of the flag when you
put it down on the moon and all that
there was an actual wind on but the the
the fact that people are bound up in
conspiracy theories about the moon
landing shows that people are willing to
place an interpretation of events that
far exceeds the evidence for that
interpretation and something we should
watch out for in politics all the time
is looking at a series of events and
then creating a narrative to explain the
series of events as opposed to what may
be the more plausible narrative which is
maybe these events don't have anything
to do with each other conspiracy
theories are a way for us to put
narrative on the world but in this case
it's a false narrative to put on the
world the reason that I don't believe
that this was done on a soundstage is
because it was not done on a soundstage
it is because there is solid evidence
that we did in fact launch people to the
moon that it would have required not
just a few people or whatever acquired
tens of thousands of people to be
involved in a conspiracy and one of the
one of the things about conspiracies
that conspiracies the conspiracies that
actually happen usually are fairly small
because it's hard to keep a secret like
that for that long
Sampson says hi Ben you often talk about
the United States needing to become a
more virtuous Society again how religion
is a great way to do so I think the case
could be made that many people on the
right also see their politics as their
religion and source of identity what is
the difference between that and a
leftist yes I'm not talking about racism
and white supremacy so I agree with this
I think there are a lot of people on the
right who see politics as religion and
are willing to follow a strong leader
and who are willing to substitute
political principle for a feeling of
religious observance who believe that if
you disagree with them politically this
means that you are evil in some way now
I'm not saying there's no such thing as
an evil belief system I think they're I
think communism is an evil belief system
I think Nazism is an evil belief system
however if you are saying that not based
on the lack of virtue in those systems
but based on this agreement about tax
rates and property distribution rights
and all of that then I feel inking more
than that if you're linking somebody's
identity to the political views that
they hold without saying okay love this
and love the sinner hate the sin and
then you are making a very large mistake
I I fully a
agree that there are people on the right
who have been sucked into spending more
time thinking about political issues
than about their fellow man and what
that leads to is actually less of a of
an open debate and less of an open
conversation because if you share
general moral principles with someone
you're gonna have a lot easier
conversation about the political
ramifications of those moral principles
than if you do not now I will say that
there is a reaction on the right to the
religious treatment of politics on the
left and that is for the right to harden
its flanks so the left I think has
gotten a lot more religious than the
right because they were irreligious in
the first place typically the much more
secular and so that religious principle
has become if you disagree with us about
environmentalism you're damned to hell
flame forever and the right has
responded by saying well you're saying
we're damned to hell flame you you guys
believe in abortion on demand I mean I'm
talking about health land that seems
like a pretty good place to go there
listen I don't want to downplay serious
political disagreements because there
are serious political disagreements the
difference between you know actual
practice of actual religion and the
practice of politics as religion is that
politics as religion inherently involves
government compulsion that's what
politics is all about it's not merely
about convincing each other with regard
to arguments without regard to the
government politics is about using the
power of government to enforce your will
the problem is when politics becomes
religion then government and religion
are the same and you have what is
effectively a secular theocracy and
there I do see some people on the right
who are falling into that trap the left
has been in that trap for quite a while
Ryan says hey Ben I was wondering if he
legal immigrants have constitutional
rights as per the text of the US
Constitution obviously they have human
rights but it seems weird to me that
specifically American rights apply to
non-citizens just because they cross the
border
Thanks right well it depends on the
right so obviously illegal immigrants do
not have the constitutional right to
live where they please right they can be
deported there are certain rights that
the Constitution applies to any person
living within the borders of the United
States and subject to the jurisdiction
thereof so you're not allowed to just go
in and beat the living hell like the
police can't go and beat the living hell
out of any illegal immigrant for no
reason so there are certain rights that
apply to anybody living within our
borders but it's not every
constitutional right not every
constitutional right applies to illegal
immigrants I mean one of the questions
is can you tell somebody's in the legal
immigrant right
to bat or not that's that's not clear so
you have to assume they're an American
citizen until you have proof otherwise
presumably Bryan's has been am I taking
crazy pills this question of citizenship
has appeared on the census for more than
a hundred years it is public record most
census questionnaires asked for
birthplace appearance immigration legal
status mutt many literally have a
citizenship column on the census form
this has been standard procedure for
years what am I missing what are people
arguing about excellent question
they're arguing over stupidity the left
doesn't want this question on the census
because they believe that the Trump
administration is trying to gather
information about how many illegal
immigrants live in districts for
purposes of redistricting which by the
way should be done that that app we
should have districts that are drawn
based on the number of American citizens
living in a district not on the number
of people including folks who cannot
vote or take part in American politics
living in those districts but basically
I think that this is this is animus
against Trump frankly it's animus
against Republicans I don't see a
rational reason not to ask that question
Matthew says hey Ben I've been listening
to Milton Friedman lately it's been
common knowledge the FDR and his New
Deal extended the Great Depression by
eight years where could I find some good
resources on this to read more on it so
there was a good study from UCLA
Anderson School of Business that came
out a few years ago if you search
Anderson School of Business study Great
Depression it'll come up talking about
how the Great Depression was lengthened
by eight years also there's sort of a
variation between the Vienna School of
Economics in the Chicago School of
Economics and what exactly led to the
Great Depression Hayek wrote about it so
did Milton Friedman Friedman basically
suggest that it was a lack of inflation
in the monetary supply was the
contraction of the monetary supply Hayek
suspects and members of the Viennese
School of Economics suspect that it was
government intervention ISM tariffs and
trade barriers and actually a bubble
that was created by the federal
government in terms of currency in the
1920s that led to the ease of credit in
the 1920s that led to the crash there's
a very good book called Chicago a Vienna
or Chicago moves by Marx Kuzon that
talks specifically about that argument
if you want a book that talks about the
failures of FDR's policy during the
Great Depression amedy slays has an
excellent book about this as well let's
see
Rohan says Ben Elon Musk has said that
he would like to see a permanent human
presence on Mars having a
self-sustaining outpost on Mars would
serve as an insurance policy if
something disastrous were to happen to
humanity on earth what are your thoughts
on this
you think space exploration has the
ability to serve as a social fabric
meaning it would unite Americans allow
us to move past identity policy and
leftist intersectionality best Rohan
well yeah I mean I think would be great
I think that what you on musk is talking
about by colonizing the colonizing Mars
that'd be fantastic and then humanity
totally should do that if we can and it
would be a worthwhile mission a useful
mission now here is the big issue is
that going to solve the problems that we
have here on earth no because we're
human beings and human beings have
problems we can go anywhere and have
problems we can travel across seas into
distant lands and still have those
problems within 200 years of us
colonizing Mars within 50 years of us
colonize Mars there will be
intersectional battles over land
redistribution on Mars human beings are
always gonna be human beings human
nature is always gonna be human nature
now increased amounts of territory are
going to are going to presumably ease
some of the problems but it depends how
hard it is to colonize Mars I assume
people aren't just gonna be flying up
there in their own personal spaceships
and then planting the flag on a bit of
territory where they put some rocks down
the way that we did when when people
crossed America across the continent to
lay out a homestead for example I assume
that a Mars colony would be a lot more
organized top-down so human nature is
always gonna be human nature as these
the short answer may have says hey man
you say our healthcare system is broken
and the universal health care as the
left is promoting it is not the solution
I agree on both fronts where do you
think should be what do you think should
be done to improve America's health care
system from where it is now I've been a
listener of your podcast for a while
recently became a daily water subscriber
well appreciate it so there's a very
good report by Eric Roy that that I've
been reading through that has some kind
of temporary fixes and solutions for the
health care system in the United States
relies a lot on health savings accounts
that transition away from employer-based
health care and more toward the and more
toward individually based healthcare
where you are responsible for purchasing
your own insurance and thus when you
lose your job you don't necessarily lose
your insurance obviously being able to
sell insurance across state lines it
would help deregulation of the insurance
industry would certainly help lowering
licensing requirements in particular
areas of Medicine would help greater
price transparency on drugs would
certainly help as I say Eric Roy is I
think probably the leading scholar in
America on this and he has about a 300
page report that is well worth while
kind of browse
I intend on going through it at some
point in a future episode maybe I'll
have avec on one of our Sunday specials
and we can talk about all of the
solutions David says dear Ben is there a
point where the 2020 candidates will
reach the end of the radical flank what
would that look like thanks David no
there is no point at which they reach
the end of the radical plank it is free
everything all the way down now in terms
of policy none of it will apply in terms
of policy none of this stuff will be
done it's all nonsense Angela says what
are your critiques of Nicci's for
critiques on Christianity so first of
all that is a very obscure question so I
would actually have to look up to remind
myself what Nietzsche's for critiques on
Christianity are so I'm going to punt on
that now because I frankly don't know
those off the top of my head he I know
that his sort of generalized critique of
Christianity which is that it created a
slave mentality where meekness was
supposed to serve as a substitute for
strength and that the poor would would
rule the earth and the meek would rule
the earth and so it's an anti
meritocracy I think that that is a
complete mystery of Christianity I also
think it's complete mystery of Judaism
he sort of conflates the two I don't
think that that is right he says that
Christianity is about victimization
basically and it's about pity I don't
think that that is correct I think
Christianity in my read and again I'm
not a Christian scholar but I am you
know more knowledge about Judaism so
I'll talk about Judaism Judaism is not
about a victim mentality which he sort
of suggested is Judaism is about the
idea that you have obligations and
duties to God and you are obligated to
fulfill those duties to God regardless
of whether you believe yourself to be a
victim in the first place it doesn't say
that the last shall be first and the
first shall be last or any of that sort
of stuff in a practical sense what it is
saying is that in a moral sense people
who are more moral in a better time will
reap the benefit of their morality I am
NOT a fan of Nietzsche's morality I
think that Nietzsche's morality is is I
think is his critique of what happens
when secularism takes over is exactly
right I think that his belief that
Christianity falling away would lead to
a better world is exactly wrong and was
proved wrong in his own country within
the next few years
let's see Sara says howdy Ben what are
your thoughts on robot empires empires
being introduced in baseball games I've
heard some people say it strengthens the
integrity of the game I am totally for
robot
I am 100% for robot empires I want more
pitches called correctly I don't want to
change me strike zone
I don't want pitch framing to be the big
issue at a game I want to know an
objective level I like data I want to
know on an objective level whether a
pitch is a ball or a strike I think
hitters would like that I think pitchers
would like that then it's just a
straight-up competition between the
players making the umpire of the issue
is really dumb Paulsen final question
Paul says my husband and I just had our
first child well I would like to quit my
job and raise for myself he thinks she
won't develop social skills if she
doesn't go to daycare could you please
share your thoughts on daycare vs.
raising kids at home I've seen very
little evidence that going to daycare
actually creates more social skills than
going to school when you are five years
old for example I'm just I don't think
that the data is there to support that
idea now but that's it my kids went to
preschool my kids right now are in
preschool so you know III think that
there's nothing wrong with sending our
kids to preschool my wife works
obviously but at the same time you know
raising your kids at home and being home
with your kids there's nothing wrong
with that either you're gonna make
playdates you're not just gonna be at
home with your kids all the time you're
gonna make play teja gonna meet other
kids you're gonna bring them to church
groups kids will find a way to socialize
and you will find ways for your kids to
socialize you don't necessarily have to
send a care in the care of another adult
you know be one adult for 30 kids
depends on the daycare honestly it also
depends on the quality of the daycare
okay time for some things I like and
then some things I hate extra-long show
today so things that I like so I've had
a chance to sit down with Bill Whittle I
mentioned this before Apollo 11 what we
saw go subscribe right now it's great
okay this is the 50th anniversary of the
Apollo 11 moon landing i sat with bill a
little bit yesterday and we talked about
what exactly happened with Apollo 11 why
it's so important welcome to Apollo 11
mission control um what's left of it
anyway the space race 12 years of open
warfare between two superpowers we used
our best missiles our best pilots I
didn't engineer we employed aircraft
carriers radar stations all the military
hardware we had to
defeat our ideological nemesis when each
team had over 20,000 nuclear warheads
apiece the space race was the defining
act of the second half of the 20th
century years ago men from Planet Earth
first set foot upon the moon you owe it
to yourself and a history to experience
the Space Age from the inside and see
how it took hundreds of small steps to
get to that one giant leap I'm Bill
Whittle and this is what we saw well
Bill Whittle I'm so glad that you could
stop by a bill of course is hosting a
brand new podcast Apollo 11 what we saw
so bill tell us about what this podcast
is actually going to be well we had four
segments of about an hour each the final
one turned into almost two so the great
news is while every segment talks a bit
about the Apollo 11 mission I get to
break that down into different areas but
the great thing is we basically cover
the entire space race from Chinese
rocket assisted arrows to SpaceX landing
twin boosters on the Falcon Heavy launch
and you know one of the things I
realized Ben is the people who have so
much trouble believing that this
happened have trouble believing it
happened because they're told that the
moon landing just kind of parachuted
into the world you know we're watching
you know all in the family hey we cut to
hold on news announcement we've landed
on the moon apparently and what they
don't see is that every single 3-4 weeks
prior to that for four or five years
there's just another mission going a
little bit further a little bit further
a little bit further a little bit
further and we get to talk about all of
them no series is beautiful I mean it
looks beautiful it sounds so what do you
think was the importance of the moon
landing I mean we obviously all pay
attention to it because it's amazing in
and of itself but what do you think was
sort of the greater impact of the of the
moon landing Kennedy caught Kennedy
caught two things with that famous moon
landing speech of his and I don't even
know if he know that if he knew that he
caught him but he said we want to do
this not because it is easy but because
it is hard and what he selected was the
hardest thing to do that would that you
could it was the hardest thing to do in
the world at the time
and so we had been so badly humiliated
by the Soviets this is that you know
we're we're we're is a war with the
Soviet Union we've got 20,000 nuclear
weapons so today we've got test pilots
aircraft carriers all this stuff we
can't use them because if we do there
goes you know all of our cities and
there's two so what this was was a way
for us to showcase our technology in our
and our ability and impress third world
countries and all the rest without
actually killing each other but it's all
about missiles and pilots and radars and
all that stuff so Kennedy said what is
the hardest thing we can do and since
we'd been so humiliated since Sputnik he
realized that the American people would
would what they would think of
themselves more than what the rest of
the world would think of it but the main
thing he said that really got it is is
that opening sentence he says we choose
to go to the moon and that's it once you
make the choice to go it's just an
engineering problem that was the hard
part that was that that was the the
hurdle to go into the moon was making
the decision to go one of the things
that you talked about in the series is
the uncertainty of the people who are
involved in this project as to whether
it was going to work and we sort of take
it for granted that the thing worked but
that was a knife's edge thing it sounds
like for her the vast majority of the of
the planning armstrong and aldrin
admitted after the mission that they
figured they had a 50/50 chance of
getting home which is not the kind of
thing you want to do it all mccoy knits
heads you keep on going with your day
tales you know close the door and turn
on the car in the garage but that's one
of the reasons why they deserve the
heroism of three Apollo one astronauts
died in a fire in the capsule that was
so horrific and I get a chance to go a
little bit into those details and I go
into those details not because it's it's
gruesome but I don't do it because it's
it's just kind of macabre I do it
because people need to understand the
courage it took to take the risks they
took the Apollo 1 crew had complained
about all of this flammable material in
the capsule and when this capsule caught
fire and all three of them died in the
fire when they got the door open they it
took over an hour to get him out of the
capsule because the nylon had fused them
into the side of the of the capsule now
that's not you know that's not a pretty
image
but that image is something that every
single guy who flew those missions had
in the back of his mind and and that's
why you need to tell that part of the
story because of the heroism but to be
honest with you since I was I was look I
was an astronaut when I was five I
didn't want to be I was it's just
paperwork you had to sort it out so I
really grown up as an experimental test
pilot and stuff and I the thing I like
most about the series is we get a lot of
the really strange really odd backstage
stuff that nobody really gets to talk
about I mean since you get into such an
inordinate level of detail with with
regard to what exactly happened with
Apollo 11 what do you make of all the
people who remain conspiracy theorists
who think this is all shot on some
backstage lot somewhere yeah
well I used to get a lot more angry at
them that I do now and having done I
mean I knew the space program very well
but having done the research I did I
realized that the reason as I said that
so many people have a hard time
believing it is analogous to the fact
that you say that the Wright brothers
went down to Kitty Hawk in 1903 and
built an f-22 Raptor and and and the
Wright brothers can't build enough 22r
after but they didn't they built a a
wooden thing with canvas wings which
evolved into the biplanes of World War
one with canvas wings which evolved into
the Allwood hurricane in World War two
which evolved into the p-51 now I get
jets we get the Sabre we get the f4 were
supersonic fly by wire with the f16 we
get stealth of the f-117 we get radars
with the the f15 better engines with the
118 and then you can build an f-22 and
the entire purpose of this show is to
take a look at every single one of those
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
small steps that got us to that giant
leap and you know now that we look back
on this and we haven't been back to the
moon in a man mission since what's
changed I mean is that the scope of
American ambition is that our belief in
ourselves what do you what do you think
has changed in terms of how we view
space I think if I think we will go back
I didn't think so three years ago I
really I thought I thought this was
gonna be the pinnacle of human history
July 20th 1969 but I changed my mind in
the last couple years what I think is
going to happen is you can measure the
greatness of America
by the fact that this country got bored
with going to the moon you know I mean
you got to think really it's really what
happened we got went to the moon yeah
all right I'm done what's next we spent
two generations essentially in orbit
with space shuttles and Skylab and stuff
we're essentially retracing John Glenn's
flight from you know 1962 and and so we
spent two generations going nowhere but
with SpaceX and Blue Origin and all the
rest of this stuff we're seeing a new
kind of enthusiasm and as I say in that
in the podcast I was 10 years old at the
Plaza Hotel when they actually stepped
foot on the moon and we had the windows
open and down in Central Park there were
probably 30 or 40,000 people watching
these projection screen TVs and when he
stepped on the moon this shear just came
up you know it's just this unbelievable
sound never heard at a football game
anything like it but I did hear it from
the from the Millennials who were in
side the SpaceX building when those two
boosters came down and landed it was
that same almost unbelievable pitch of
excitement and I think the second time
is gonna be a lot looser a lot more fun
you know we're gonna have any company
been any company who's whose recovery
ship is official name is of course I
still love you those guys are going to
Mars and and I don't have any doubt
about that at all well bit a little via
the series is called Apollo 11 what we
saw everybody should go check it out you
can subscribe over at Apple podcast you
can get it at iTunes anywhere you get
your podcasts go subscribe right now it
really is terrific bill thanks for
stopping by good to see you pleasure
buddy I got to go back to the
underground control chamber now where
I've been since I was 10 you know we've
Mission Control back up there in case
the Soviets launch a nuclear attack and
I basically been there since 1969 well
as long as they don't have Twitter
you're better off so what gets in MIT
bill you bet your buddy I agree with me
go up go and subscribe right now Apollo
11 what we saw okay time for a quick
thing that I hate
all righty so here is a very stupid
thing there is a person named Dan hasla
Forrest and he writes a piece for the
Washington Post today he's an often
public speaker on media franchises
cultural theory and political economy he
works as assistant professor in the
Media Studies department of Utrecht
University and he has a piece today in
the Washington Post titled
The Lion King is a fascistic story no
remake can change that oh my god I mean
last I checked the Lion King was
actually just a story about lions but
apparently not apparently it's about the
evils of democracy here's what this
columnist writes last november's isn't
he broke the internet with its teaser
trailer for the Lion King
this 93 second video gave millions of
people chills by faithfully recreating
key moments from the original films
beloved opening number
but as nostalgic a circle of life may
make us feel this bombastic scene is
also a painful reminder of the film's
ideological agenda it introduces us to a
society where the weak have learned to
worship at the feet of the strong oh my
god
basically the Lion King is just Hamlet
right I mean that is the basis of the
Lion King it is the uncle who tries to
kill the father and Mufasa dies spoiler
alert and then the son has to do
something about all of that it's if
Hamlet were a straightforward story then
it would look like The Lion King it's
obviously based on the Lion King with
with the toucan is Polonius and the
whole thing okay the whole thing the
fact that this is now being taken
seriously as some sort of metaphor for
why monarchy is good is hilarious to me
we may be a little bit too we may be
over analyzing this thing a little bit
too bit too much this comment says as we
watch the herbivores congregate to bow
down before their newborn ruler The Lion
King offers us a seductive worldview in
which absolute power goes unquestioned
and where the weak and the vulnerable
are fundamentally inferior in other
words Lion King offers us a fascist
ideology writ large there seems to be no
way out for the forthcoming remake the
first thing to understand about the Lion
King is that it isn't in any way about
lions or any other animal species no it
it kind of is and it says so in the
title The Lion King and then also there
are only animal
and no humans in it it's amazing how the
left will struggle to say that certain
things are not metaphors and then
they'll immediately say that this is a
metaphor for fascism on earth as in
every fable a variety of cute and cuddly
figures stand in for human societal
organizations mapping our internalized
social hierarchies on today's pristine
and neutral world of the animal kingdom
renders these power dynamics natural
common-sense and desirable okay so first
of all let's just be real about the
animal kingdom lions eat zebras when
they are called the king of the king of
the forest king of the jungle yeah this
has been a thing for quite a while and
that is because the lion is the apex
predator in this particular scenario
that's called nature by using the
predator-prey relationships to
allegorize human power the film almost
inevitably incorporates the white
supremacist worldview so now believe it
or not the argument is that the Lion
King is about white supremacy now last I
checked Mufasa his voice in the Lion
King is James Earl Jones who is black
Simba in the remake is played by Donald
Glover who is black Nala who is his wife
he's played by by out and by Beyonce who
is black
Surabhi who is his mom is played by
alpha alpha uttered who is black James
Earl Jones is still Mufasa and still
black but apparently this is it's all
white supremacy it's always you probably
Wow obviously such fables conserve
politically diverse ends as this
columnist for The Washington Post George
Orwell's Animal Farm employed a similar
allegory to make class distinctions more
blatantly visible and to criticize
authoritarian systems of power Disney's
own Robin Hood adaptation similarly
associated power systems with animal
food chains but used its allegory to
poke fun at the obvious greed and
corruption that defined the predatory
ruling class but the sympathies of the
Lion King lie elsewhere doubling down on
Disney's historical obsession with
patriarchal monarchies it places the
audience's point of view squarely with
the autocratic lions whose pride Rock
literally looks down upon all of
society's weaker groups a kind of Trump
Tower of the African savannah
so now Mufasa is from man I love these
lions they're unbelievable
Simba let's go eat a zebra
when grandpa tree ark Mufasa explains
patiently to his son how this division
of power works he emphasizes that the
King must maintain balance in their
kingdom this seems fine when we think
about the environment where balance
sounds great
as they're living in the environment and
aren't animals so yes but when we
consider he's really explaining to his
own heir why is perfectly fine to behave
dictatorial the Lions perspective feels
a lot more unsettling bad as it is that
the powerful are presented as inherently
superior to all other things things get
substantially worse once the hyenas are
introduced with the Lions standing in
for the ruling class and the good
herbivores embodying society's decent
law-abiding citizens the hyenas
transparently represent the black brown
and disabled bodies that are forcefully
excluded from this fascist society
so the hyenas are black and brown and to
say where's the disabled is there a
disabled hyena a guy you know rolling
around in a wheelchair in Lion King did
I miss that part and they're black and
brown as opposed to the Lions whose
voices are all black folks noticeably
marked by their ethnically coded street
accents the hyenas blatantly symbolized
racist and anti-semitic stereotypes of
verminous groups that form an inherent
threat to society oh that's what's going
on it's the Jews how do I miss this
whole thing I mean maybe I missed it
because they're obviously supposed to be
Nazis they have like an actual Nazi
March with goose-stepping in the
original Lion King movie when scar sings
be prepared the hyenas actually marched
like Nazis is an obvious Nazi allegory
nonetheless this is so this is so great
they this foul betrayal of tradition is
predictably orchestrated by scar the
misfit lion who's opportunistic desire
to advance the status of minorities
echoes the way conservatives speak of
liberal politicians when they act as if
compassion is merely opportunism
simultaneously his effeminate gestures
and lack of interest in heterosexual
reproduction mark him as queer like the
vast majority of other villains in
Disney's exclusively heterosexual world
what in the world what the guys did you
ever did I miss this I feel like did you
forget that all the villains and Disney
films are gay I feel like I missed this
part wow that's that's that's amazing
III Jafar in Aladdin literally wants to
have sex with
Esmond throughout the entire film and
Skaar is hitting on Simba's mom if I if
I don't miss remember adding insult to
injury the social outcasts rebellion
against Mufasa autocratic regime is
explicitly associated with the imagery
of goose-stepping Nazis they're actually
the good guys but as so often in
Hollywood films the explicit Nazi
iconography serves primarily to distract
us from the hero's own fascism
Simba's final ascent to the throne his
masculine roar returning scars dystopia
to academic natural state is nothing
nothing less than the Fuehrer principle
at work the idea that those we entrust
with positions of leadership are blessed
with a natural even divine superiority
unbelievable unbelievable now that
Disney has become by far the most
powerful entertainment company in the
world we have seen several attempts to
update and correct its ideological
payload Maleficent and its forthcoming
sequel changed a deeply deeply sexist
fairy tale into a feminist parable about
sexual abuse
Aladdin made at least some attempt to
mitigate the original film's
Islamophobia Beauty and the Beast
included a very minor openly gay
character the new area will be a mermaid
of color and Mulan has been overhauled
to become less offensive to Chinese
audiences but we should get rid of the
Lion King presumably these people are
the worst ruining everything in American
life and culture making everything worse
all in the name of locus well done
everyone well we'll be back here a
little bit later today with two
additional hours of content as if we
haven't already given you enough and
then we'll be back here on Monday so if
you don't see it until then have a
wonderful weekend i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright day Lee Weyer
2019 hey guys over on the Matt Walsh
show today a former Trump staffer claims
that she was the victim of battery when
Trump forcibly kissed her she says well
there's video now of the incident in
question and it seems to completely
vindicate Trump we're gonna talk about
that i'll play the video and we'll talk
about what we can learn from this from
this whole case also i want to discuss a
real example of true courage and female
empowerment this is a teenage girl in
connecticut who is standing up against
the madness of allowing biological boys
into girls sports this is something this
as i said is real empowerment this is
courage this is something feminist
should be celebrating but for the most
part they're not and we're going to talk
about that today also over on the Matt
Walsh show